I'm shocked that this has happened now
and so soon you know I talked to a lot
of people who are close to Twitter I've
talked to some of the founders at times
and all of them have been very publicly
supportive of Dick Costolo as CEO Dick
Costolo has told me time and again that
he and the board are aligned he will be
the CEO of this company he feels that he
has the support of evan williams and
Jack Dorsey who founded this company and
now we're hearing that Chuck Dorsey is
coming in as interim CEO this is a guy
who's currently running another
multi-billion dollar company square you
know that said there has been a lot of
momentum behind investors who are just
not happy with Twitter's performance you
and I were just talking about Chris
Sacca a few minutes ago who released an
8,500 word missive about what he thinks
that Twitter can do to be better I asked
him many many times if he thinks that
dick costolo should still be the CEO and
he was publicly in that moment
supportive of Dick Costolo he felt that
dick costolo could get some of these
things done that he's asking to be done
but the reality is 1 billion people have
have come to Twitter have tried Twitter
and they haven't stuck around this is a
company that's suffering lagging user
growth lagging revenue this is a company
that so many people including myself
think can be bigger than than it already
is there's so much that goes on on
Twitter live tweets from basketball
players in the middle of a game you know
periscoping behind the scenes but that
kind of stuff is too difficult for
regular people who don't understand that
service to find Twitter actually takes a
lot of work and these are some things
that dick costolo hasn't been able to
fix since he's been the CEO there's been
a lot of turnover five product heads in
five years there was a lot of talk that
it certainly seemed like dick had
assembled a team the team that could
finally execute on these things he
brought in Anthony noto the new CFO he
brought in and promoted a new product
guy named Kevin will and it certainly
seemed like things were getting in order
but it doesn't seem like the board has
confidence in him at this
point and Emily I don't obviously want
you to speculate on what triggered this
right now but in your experience who had
been pushing for some kind of change at
the top and how quickly was that voice
actually growing because Twitter is
still affirming it's a second quarter
guidance it's not like all of a sudden
things that magically changed so first
of all Wall Street Wall Street has been
pretty hard on Dick Costolo I mean there
have been people out there time and
again saying the CEO of Twitter should
be fired so there was a lot of pressure
from the outside people who were not
within the company saying that this
company can be more that it can be I
mean over the years there has been so
much drama with regard to this company
Nick Bilton wrote an entire book on it
and you know as far as I can tell in
many situations it seemed that the board
has not necessarily been a line there
been a lot of people rotating into the
board and rotating out of the board
there's a lot of a lot of bad blood on
the floor quite frankly with how you
know Evan Williams was a CEO then Jack
Dorsey came in then dick came in and and
you know they simply couldn't seem to
get it together on the inside couldn't
get aligned on the inside and there's
always been a question about whether the
Twitter board has been completely
aligned because they're all of these
competing voices Emily with your
experience with Jack Dorsey what might
he bring to the company that is
different than dick costolo it might
help it so one of the things jack is is
is the product guy he's very much in
favor of simplicity and that's always
been his push he also is very supportive
of the live feed and keeping live as
sort of the the cornerstone of twitter
twitter has been experimenting with live
and delayed tweets as well to try to
help surface these tweets that happen
maybe eight hours ago that are really
cool but baby don't show up in your feed
because you only see what was written
five seconds ago and Jack Dorsey as i
understand it certainly cares about
keeping that chronological feed alive
but at the same time there's a question
of how do they make that easier for
people like my mom who's a huge facebook
user to get into twitter and to
understand Twitter without having to do
too much work figuring out who to follow
figuring out when to log on figuring out
user names I mean user names are very
difficult to understand on Twitter
search still leaves a lot to be desired
it's a very complicated product that
does have a lot of potential Emily you
know you know Wall Street as you said
has been really rough on Dick Costolo do
you think you know you say Jack's gonna
come back to be interim but in terms of
a long-term CEO do you expect that
they'll look outside the company or
other people inside the company that
could rise up and likely lead you know
be the new leadership so there are
certainly a lot of people inside the
company that have been talked about for
example Adam Bain has turned Twitter
into an incredible business I mean you
know the the questions about Twitter
have a lot more to do with user growth
than revenue growth and that's really
been Adam Adam Baynes you know project
he has turned Twitter into a revenue
engine Anthony nodo the CFO obviously
spent a long time at Goldman Sachs does
he have the sort of product sense the
product vision that Twitter needs some
people would question whether whether
indeed he does have that I mean one of
Twitter's main difficulties is that it
hasn't had a founder one of its founders
as a CEO and I was talking to Chris
Sacca about this very thing you know
does Dick Costolo have the respect of
the troops because he's not a founder
how much more difficult is it for him to
execute on his vision because it's not a
founder and he's not a founder and so I
could say it is difficult founder CEOs
you know regardless of whether they're
right or wrong people just defer to them
they're allowed to be weirder they're
allowed to take bigger risks and Dick
never had that that said there are names
being tossed around here in Silicon
Valley I've heard Kevin systems name the
founder of Instagram I've heard his name
talked around but at the same time I've
also heard a lot of people saying but
really who could really do this better I
mean they can't get Mark Zuckerberg but
it does certainly lend some more you
know some more you know more thought to
this idea that maybe Google or Facebook
comes in and buys Twitter you literally
stole the next question right out of my
mouth is that will Twitter net in
evitable East a an independent company
what would you wear would you please
place the odds on someone bigger like a
google or
facebook coming along and taking them
out I think historically Jack Dorsey
Evan Williams they have never wanted to
sell that this company Mark Zuckerberg
tried to buy this company several years
ago and they did not sell Chris Sacca
just told me this amazing anecdote about
being in Hawaii and getting the call and
listening on speakerphone as Evan Jack
and fizz went over the terms that Mark
Zuckerberg was offering them and he said
at that time there was never any doubt
that they wanted this to be a big
independent company that said you know
Mark Zuckerberg for example has shown no
fear of putting down a lot of money in
making big bets and Mark Zuckerberg at
least according to Chris Sacca would
love to own Twitter would love to
improve some of the things that he
thinks is wrong with Twitter I you know
who who knows a Twitter would certainly
add a lot of value to a company like
Google that has never gotten social
right but is it really going to happen
speculation about a twitter deal a big
twitter deal has been happening for
years and it's never happened